JONATHAN CHASE: We've been
working with BigQuery recently
to replace our existing data
in analytics infrastructure.
SADA has been able to help us
get the information we need
or answer the questions that
we've had about Google Cloud
Platform.
And this was a big
decision for us.
While it's great that GCP
makes things easy enough
that we can get there on
our own for the most part,
it's great to have
a partner like SADA
that we can call
at any time to help
us get the rest of the way.
The reason that Cedexis
likes Google Cloud
Platform and BigQuery,
in particular, so much
is because it makes
things so easy for us
as far as the analytics go.
We've had people dedicated
full time to supporting
our old analytics platform.
And now, those people can work
on more interesting things
than doing operations support
for relational database.
Operating in the
cloud is difficult.
It's nice to have good partners.
It's nice to have a great
platform to work on.
SADA and GCP make that possible.
[MUSIC PLAYING]